welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this
episode were going back to Avengers
endgame
firstly I just want to give a huge thank
you for everyone that checked out our
first breakdown on the film and this
video we're going to be going over some
of your submissions new things that
Marvel have revealed and other elements
that we've spotted since dropping it if
your comment made this video then we'll
be dropping your screen name up top so
keep an eye out and thank you for being
awesome this video is gonna be pointing
out a lot of Easter eggs that I haven't
really seen many people pick up upon so
I hope you enjoy it there will of course
be heavy spoilers here so if you got
dusted during the snap and haven't seen
the movie yet then I highly suggest that
you turn off now make 'shy subscribe to
the channel and please drop a thumbs up
if you've been enjoying our marvel
breakdown so far without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this let's get into a breakdown
of Avengers endgame okay so this amazing
Easter egg was recently dropped by
Marvel and it shows just how much the
studio focused on iconography and
symbolism totally socks arc reactor not
only provided the hero with a new heart
but it also in some ways added some real
heart to the series itself the arc
reactor became a symbol that has been
splashed across t-shirts phone cases and
a lot more it's now at a point where
it's hard to think about Iron Man
himself without immediately imagining
the beaming blue light emanating from
his chest it pulls the universe together
and it's difficult to not tear up when
we watch the arc reactor floating off
into the lake at Tony Stark's funeral
I'm not crying you're crying but the
shape and color of it also played a big
part in the reunion of the Avengers
after the events of Civil War the group
separated and it wasn't until end game
that they reunited as a whole their
first mission is a team involved
traveling back in time and just before
doing so they put their fists all
together not only showing a bit of
social distancing yay but also the shape
of the arc reactor itself around this
symbol the team reformed and ultimately
went on to save the universe it's a
great little easter egg and I'm so glad
that Marvel released this one because
I don't think anyone would have spotted
it otherwise now not only does endgame
pull the Avengers together once more but
it also sends them on their separate
ways by the end of it Tony and Natasha
die Clint is reunited with his family
Hulk hangs out with Bucky and Sam door
goes off with the Guardians and Steve
goes back in time the MCU clearly needs
people to replace them and we did get
this lace throughout the subtext too far
from home this centered around Peter
becoming the Next Iron Man but there
were more hints in that that he would
embody certain other members of The
Avengers too when he's on the bridge in
London about to tackle Mysterio head-on
Peter makes a shield and grabs a part of
a drone which he then ties together with
a seat belt so that he can use it as a
weapon Peter has the perfect shield and
thing that he can swing because of it
and I think this is actually a nod to
Captain America in endgame after gaining
manya he begins to swing around before
charging at Thanos Peter holds her in a
similar position showing that he now
embodies some of the pillars of the
Avengers and I love how this stirs up
the imagery of Thor's hammer cap shield
and of course his mentor Iron Man now
seeing Tony go was tough for all of us
but at least we can take some solace in
the fact that he did get to hug his
father and tell him that he did his best
we've already mentioned how this tied
back to the bar scene in Civil War but
in Iron Man 2 Tony tells fury that his
father never used to hug him so this is
a great little exchange between the two
throughout the MCU Tony has told people
that he never likes to be handed
anything and this has been referenced in
Iron Man The Avengers and a lot more
making it one of the weirdest character
beats well ever however in the elevator
Tony's dad handsome flowers and he takes
them immediately when Tony's dad puts
his hand out he says shake it don't pull
it and Tony later gets the idea to shake
the stones off the glove instead of
pulling it like how he did in infinity
war which as we all know went pretty
badly now a big thing in the film that
really shocked audiences was the reveal
of Thor who since killing Thanos had
turned to alcohol and Pizza duh Marvel
even predicted lockdown life this is
reflected in his surroundings and the
people that he hangs out with if you
look closely at Korg
you will see
masses started to grow on him which
similar to stones shows how long he's
probably been stationary for at one
point in the film we also see Thor
putting eye drops in but he of course
only puts them in one because the other
one is robotic Thor comes face to face
with his mother and Asgard and similar
to the Tony and Howard interaction it's
an emotional moment when Frigga asks
Thor what he's wearing he states he used
to wear this all the time instead of I
wear this all the time because he's from
the future and this hints at him being
placed out of time Frigga hints that she
knows of the feature because she was
raised by witches and this is a callback
to thor ragnarok in that thor and loki
go to Shady Acres just to catch it being
demolished and Loki says he didn't know
this would happen because he can't see
the future as he's not a witch so taking
all that together we do know in the
Marvel Universe that witches can tell
the future and that's how fritter is
able to work well you know that that and
the fact that he he looks completely
different anyway
endgame is laced with a feeling of grief
throughout but the stages of it pop up
at several points with each of the
surviving Avengers representing the five
stages of it Tony represents denial
because he got lucky and didn't lose his
family
Tony ended up turning his back on the
world and he was living a peaceful happy
life with his wife and kid in complete
denial of the despair going on Clint
represents anger which is pretty obvious
through his actions and Steven etosha
represent bargaining as they refused to
move on even after five years when the
idea of time trouble is brought up even
though it seems ridiculous at first they
jump at it and give it their all because
they're trying to bargain with the
universe Thor sinks into depression and
completely loses his grip on life lets
himself go and the loss of his family
his home and people really weighs in on
him finally is Hulk who deals with
acceptance he is the only one who works
on bettering himself and accepts
everything that's happened even though
the character lost two times the two
opposites of his personality put their
differences aside and they accept one
another and move on Hulk plays a big
role in the film and his
snap brings everyone back now there's
actually a lot of subtle things in this
scene that show that the world is
restabilized fiercely there is sunlight
and the clouds seem to depart this is
because the oxygen around the planet was
contaminated with the ashes of all those
that died we actually saw hints of this
earlier in the film when viewing New
York and this mist was likely brought on
because of the dust that surrounded the
planet when everyone got well dusted the
birds returned as does hawkeye's wife
Laura now why this is interesting is
because she is one of the people that we
see go last in the snap as they
disappear at the star of endgame during
the scene we can hear birds chirping and
they're taken to so it's poetic how
Laura and the birds are the first to go
and also the first to return when Tony
assembles the gauntlet with rocket and
Hulk this is a direct call back to when
Howard played with the tesseract in the
first event yet that is also why rocket
says boom as in that scene Howard blew
the chamber up Dan asset is all about
balance and no more is this reflected in
the way that the gauntlet goes from
being left handed to right an infinity
war it starts off on the left and an
endgame it goes to the right which
brings everything full circle Tony calls
rocket at build-a-bear and rocket says
maybe I am it's going to play this a
joke but when Yuri watch the MCU it's
really sad in guardians rocky tells
stalo that he didn't choose to be taken
apart and put back together over and
over again and hey no wonder he thinks
he might actually be a build-a-bear
Tony re-enters stark tower through the
same window that he was thrown out of by
Loki and when he goes to see CAPA
Avengers HQ he says he just wants peace
this is a callback to Ironman in which
he states that with peace he'd be out of
the job Tony is of course out of the job
in the early stages of endgame perhaps
showing that he did find peace with his
family and finally finally finally
how are the duck arrives in the final
battle after having been seen in both
guardians movies and the kid from Iron
Man 3 is all grown up I know they're
kind of obvious ones I just got so many
comments on the last video saying I
missed them so yeah they finally made
the video we can rest now you
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these Easter eggs so comment
below and let us know if your comment
didn't make the list then apologies but
I will probably be revisiting the movie
at some point and as I had a lot of fun
with this so yeah leave your bits of
trivia below make sure you check out our
first breakdown of endgame which is
gonna be linked at the end as it
contains a ton of details that are
really thick and rich in the film if you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank-you your access to content early
if you want to come chat us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below
every month we give away free movies to
people are subscribed to the channel and
this Monty can win the Marvel phase
three part one box set and all you have
to do is comment on a video and make
sure you submit notifications on the
more videos you comment on the more you
have a chance of winning so make sure
you get involved the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of May in
the cell be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you